هو اول رئيس امريكي سابق يخضع لمحاكمه
جنائيه فيدراليه بعد انتهاء ولايته لكنها
ليست المحاكمه الوحيده التي تنتظر الرئيس
السابق دونالد ترامب يواجه الرجل مجموعه
من القضايا في عدد من الولايات
جنائيه وفدراليه
في ولايه فلوريدا وجهها ممثل الادعاء
لوائح اتهام رسميه بتهم جنائيه لترامب
تتعلق بسبع وثلاثين قضيه فيدراليه على
خلفيه حيازته وثائق سريه بعد انتهاء
ولايته
ومغادرته البيت الابيض
تتعلق احدى وثلاثون تهمه منها بالاحتفاظ
المتعمد بوثائق تختص بالامن القومي
وانتهاك قوانين حمايه الاسرار وعرقله سير
العداله ما يخالف قانونا بشان التجسس يحضر
الاحتفاظ باسرار الدوله في اماكن غير
مرخصه وغير مؤمنه توجيه الاتهامات رسميا
اعقب عثور ومصادره محققين نحو 13 الف
وثيقه من منتجع ترامب فيمارا لاجو في
ولايه فلوريدا بينها 100 وثيقه تحمل طابع
السريه تضمن التفاصيل عن قدرات النوويه
لدوله اجنبيه اضافه الى وثائق عده تتعلق
بانشطه عسكريه امريكيه واجنبيه
وتشير اللائحه الى ان الاتهامات الموجهه
لترامب تتضمن الاحتفاظ بمعلومات الدفاع
الوطني بمحض ارادته
لائحه من 24 تهمه ايضا امام محكمه نيويورك
منها دفع اموال لشراء صمت ممثله اباحيه
قبيل انتخابات عام 2016
واتهم بالتامر وتزوير سجلات تجاريه
وضريبيه والكذب على مقرطين وشركات تامين
والاحتياد في تقدير الاصول الماليه كما
يواجه ترامب تحقيق الفيدراليا وجنائيا
يتعلق بدوره في هجمات السادس من يناير عام
2021 على مبنى الكابيتون في واشنطن اضافه
لتحقيقات للاشتباه بطلوعه في محاوله
التدخل لالغاء نتائج انتخابات ولايه
جورجيا فما الذي ينتظر ترامب في حال
ادالته بتهم جنائيه فيدراليه
يعاقب القانون الامريكي بالسجن لفترات
متفاوته على التهم الموجهه للرئيس السابق
دونالد ترامب السجن لمده اقصاها 10 سنوات
للمدنين بالاحتفاظ بشكل متعمد بمعلومات
تتعلق بالدفاع الوطني
وعشرون عاما لتهمه عرقله العداله
والاحتفاظ بوثائق او سجلات حكوميه امريكيه
والمده نفسها للمدانين باخفاء مستند او
سجل بشكل غير امن اما ما يتعلق بالتخطيط
لاخفاء المستندات فيعاقب القانون عليه
بالسجن لمده اقصاها خمس سنوات والمده
ذاتها لمن يدلي باقوال كاذبه
[موسيقى]